aquí tengo un problema bastante
interesante de proporciones y en
principio puede parecer desalentador el
hecho de que aparezcan fracciones en
este problema pero a medida que lo
trabajemos paso a paso espero que
resulte ser un poco más intuitivo y este
problema dice calvin limpia tres quintas
partes de su baño con una tercera parte
de lo digamos con un tercio de una
botella de solución limpiadora a esta
razón qué fracción de la botella de
solución limpiadora necesitará calvin
para limpiar su baño completo y como
siempre te invito a que hagas una pausa
y que trates de resolver este problema
por tu propia cuenta de todos modos lo
vamos a hacer juntos en unos momentos
así que como debemos pensar esto y no
sea mi cerebro le gusta pensarlo de la
siguiente forma hay que preguntarnos
cómo nos gustaría dar la respuesta
primero y esencialmente la respuesta
podrían ser digamos un número que no
conocemos de botellas que vamos a
necesitar
para limpiar cada baño ok un número
desconocido de botellas por baño por
supuesto aquí el problema nos está
diciendo que este número en realidad es
una fracción de una botella verdad pero
en principio podría ser justamente una
fracción puede ser tres quintos o quizás
podrían ser dos botellas por baño en fin
pueden ser diversas diversos tipos de
respuesta verdad así que esencialmente
nos está preguntando la fracción de
botellas que vamos a necesitar por por
cada baño que queramos limpiar verdad al
menos del baño de calvin esto si lo
convertimos digamos en una expresión un
poquito más matemática pues sería un
número que no conocemos de botellas
por cada baño que necesitamos limpiar
verdad y lo expresamos como una fracción
como una una proporción verdad y esto es
muy útil verdad pues es claro porque las
unidades nos dicen que hay que tomar la
fracción de botellas que necesitamos por
cada baño verdad y aquí tenemos la
información nos dice tenemos que
utilizar un tercio de una botella verdad
tenemos que utilizar un tercio de
botella un tercio de botella por cada
tres quintas partes de su baño verdad
entonces hay que tomar la fracción de
esta información que tenemos un tercio
de botella por cada tres quintas partes
de su baño muy bien con esta fracción
podemos
ver que sé que aquí hay que hacer una
división verdad hay que dividir un
tercio entre tres quintos y de este lado
derecho digamos nos queda botellas
dividido entre baño verdad botellas por
cada baño así que lo único que nos resta
es hacer la división pues ya tenemos las
unidades que nos piden el problema
verdad tenemos que hacer un tercio / /
puede escribir lo mejor que nos queda un
tercio dividido entre tres quintos tres
quintos y del lado derecho vamos a tener
botellas dividido entre baño y cuando
digo dividido estamos pensando en
botellas por baño verdad necesitamos
tantas fracciones una fracción de
botellas por cada baño que queremos
limpiar y esto es igual a que bueno pues
dividir entre un tercio dividido entre
tres quintos es lo mismo que multiplicar
un tercio por el recíproco de tres
quintos que es cinco tercios así que
tendremos
un tercio por cinco tercios cinco
tercios que multiplica o bueno un tercio
por cinco tercios de botellas por baño
ok de botellas por baño botella porque
sabemos que es una fracción menor que
uno según el problema muy bien y esto es
muy fácil de calcular porque tenemos que
multiplicar 1 por 5 que son 5 y 3 por 3
son 9 tenemos 5 novenos de botella por
baño botella por baño y esta es
justamente la respuesta verdad hagamos
un breve resumen queríamos calcular
digamos la fracción de la botella de
solución limpiadora que necesitara
calvin para limpiar su baño completo
esto en términos matemáticos es una
fracción que no conocemos en principio
de botellas por baño que queramos
limpiar verdad y esto nos dice que hay
que hacer la división de la información
que ya tenemos un tercio de botella
dividido entre tres quintos de baño
verdad y eso nos da una
cuesta de 5 novenos de botellas por baño
así que este número que no conocíamos es
en realidad 5 novenos de botellas por
baño